bonjour ça va bien alors on va comment
il me faut une [ __ ]
parce que je viens un support vidéo et
je n'ai pas la télécommande et donc on a
tous des ratés mais on va commencer
comme ça j'ai fait des signes et ça va
paraître vous raconter une histoire qui
commence pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale voilà à l'époque les
britanniques bombardent lignes
allemandes avec leurs avions et les
allemands prennent saputo mal ce qui
fait qu'ils vont répondre en canardant
les avions et comme la guerre c'est pas
rigolo à peu près 50% des avions sont
abattues se sont perdus disparaissent et
ceux qui restent bas arrivent à bon port
plus ou moins endommagés on note les
anglais qui aimerait bien garder un peu
d'avions envies et des pilotes avec
engage les scientifiques pour exemple à
trouver une solution on aurait bien que
ça se passe mieux
et donc il faudrait blindés les avions
pour que les avions soient plus solides
mais un avion entièrement blindés merci
infiniment
un avion entièrement blindés ça
s'appellera un char d'assaut sa veulent
très mal à la con essayé et donc il faut
trouver les bons endroits à abelanet
nous ont fait des études donc les jeux
les chercheurs regarde les avions
rescapés et comment ça marche donc on a
des zones comme ça qui sont très touchés
d'autres qui le sont moins et l'état
major sans la base de ces données décide
de blinder les zones rouges
bah c'est une décision parfaitement
logique n'est pas une son incorrection
et bien avant moi n'était pas d'accord
avec ça il leur a dit écoutez si vous
voulez blindés ces zones là en fait vous
oubliez cependant le compte 50 % les
avions c'est qu'ils sont parvenus en
fait parce que ce que vous donne comme
information ces zones rouges c'est les
zones où l'avion peut être touché en
dommages et gravement est rentré quand
même dont faut blinder ailleurs ses
conséquences positives mais c'est hyper
important donc ça c'est le biais du du
survivant que c'est quand on oublie de
prendre en compte ceux qui sont morts
par exemple un motard ou un soldat qui
rentre sans sa tête c'est rare donc
l'équipe ont le plus important d'en
intégrer 10 et le casque je sais les
morts qui nous lisent ces les morts que
l'on tient peut-être qui me dit à la
tête il faut qu'on blinde la tête quoi
donc le bide du survivant c'est ça dont
je vous parlais c'est lui qui consiste à
oublier
les données invisible les âmes des morts
et à ne concerner que ce qu'on voit et
le problème des conférences ted c'est
peut être ça je viens pour une ambiance
parce que on a tous des informations sur
le monde
mais ce concept du monde est assez
limité on axe est une petite fraction
c'est l'impression qu'ils sont
disponibles et on pourrait savoir
beaucoup de choses en fait on pourrait
savoir tout ça mais on sait que la
petite fort ce qui est blanche et donc
on sait bien que ce n'est pas suffisant
on sait que c'est limité mais on veut
quand même avoir une opinion on veut
pouvoir prendre une décision on veut
faire des choix et donc on le fait quand
même défendre à se retenir
on n'y arrive pas pire parfois on est
obligé de prendre des décisions de voter
etc et on le fait sur la base
d'informations qui sont incomplètes et
on oublie qu'elles sont incomplètes qui
fait qu'on retient pas le ski au tour et
donc on va combler les trous avec des
inférences personnes occupent
quels sont les intérêts quelles sont mes
choix personnels que son ego mes
habitudes et donc on va on va remplir
nos nos décisions avec une explication
parfaitement rationnel mais fausse
fictif parce qu'on remplit les troupes
est donc levé lui mais des survivants
c'est de se baser sur ce qu'on voit et
d'oublier qu'on n'a pas accès au reste
mais voilà qui se pose c'est que déjà au
courant je suppose l'effet que news ça
existe tout ce qu'on alors je vous
choquer tout ce qu'on entend n'est pas
vrai parfois il ya de la publicité
il ya des propagandes dans tous les pays
il ya des pseudosciences sur toutes les
chaînes et du bullshit ça veut dire
conneries ou balivernes il ya des purs
mensonges et il faut pas les croire
ok malheureusement un courant que 20
votre voisine où votre temps de simone
votre petit cousin il les croit
malheureusement et donc comment on fait
quand on est abreuvé tous les jours de
produits que les tifs a varié et bien on
va voir comment ça
encore une fraction alors plus on entend
quand même un peu en bas en croire parce
que c'est mathématique et le problème
c'est que jusque dans cette salle je
vous regarde vous vois très bien jusque
sur les dans la salle des gens qui
regardent via internet ou sur leur écran
il ya des croyances fausses
on a tous si c'est des croyances fausses
même ici avant moi ou même pendant le
parlant je vous parle il ya des gens qui
disent des choses avec des grandes
fosses et comment est ce qu'on sait que
c'est faux que c'est pas faux mais il
faut avoir une autre est donc vous
renvoie vers ce qu'on dit les gens
avancent qu'ils étaient peut-être très
bien et vous ont armé pour être critique
mais voilà il est possible qu'on croit
des choses fausses et c'est quand même
bien dommage mais alors ça c'est des
informations relativement délicate mais
j'ai même pire à vous dire c'est que à
côté des faits que news est un truc que
vous ne connaissez pas céder mme ute
news news ça veut dire silencieux muet
c'est les choses vrai que vous ne savez
pas que vous n'entendez pas que vous ne
cherchez pas il ya plein de trucs
absolument vrai que vous n'avez aucune
chance de croire parce que vous n'êtes
pas exposés à ces choses là
donc dans ce bas côté on allait les
choses fausses qui prennent beaucoup de
place
enfin ce match serait qu'on ne cherche
pas parce qu'on n'est pas très motivée à
chercher les choses vraies ce que ces
essais c'est coûteux et donc vous venez
ici un décès la reconnaît vous venez ici
à vous payez votre place pour écouter
des gens vous avez un panel de
conférenciers et vous vous dites qui est
qu'est-ce qu'un goûter
il sait pas n'importe qui qui va parler
à part moi c'est des gens qui sont là à
qui on donne la parole parce qu'on
estime qu'ils ont un truc intéressant à
dire donc on va pas aller à interroger
le clos du coin la personne qui a raté
sa vie c'est triste c'est comme ça on
fait part on va s'intéresser à des gens
intéressants nôtres qui fait sa ba les
organisateurs qui sont adorables
ils sont là bas beaucoup mais ils ont
leur billet personnel ils ont leurs
opinions et leurs croyances
peut-être qu'ils ont leurs défauts à eux
je sais je suppose que ça devait arriver
et donc comment est ce qu ils font un
choix bas ils font un choix
qui va être ils vont prendre des autres
qu'ils soient des c'est pas les aimants
cracher ses des survivants les gens qui
ont la parole de ceux sur cette scène
c'est une infime fraction on n'a pas
accès ce que dit d'une voix qui se passe
sur la scène donc peut être que vous
avez des trucs intéressants à dire mais
et microsoft il est donc c'est moi qui
parle et donc à partir de là qu'est ce
que je peux vous raconter oui le la
devise de des conférences ted c'est des
idées qui valent la peine d'être
diffusée en gros c'est ce qui est
intéressant qui décide de sa page à vous
dire c'est les gens qui invite les gens
une idée intéressante elle n'est pas
forcément vrai ce qui est intéressant
c'est pas toujours utiles pour
comprendre le monde dont ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qui est intéressant
même bien avancé et donc on entend
régulièrement dans l'est dans le format
conférence ted un besoin ce soir mais ça
arrive fréquemment
j'aimerais qu'ils vont vous parler de
deux trucs qui sont à la mode suggère si
choquant amusant il y avait plein de
plein de moyens de trouver un truc
intéressant donc va quels sont les
filtres qu'on utilise pour choisir les
sujets et ce certes c'est intéressant
mais est ce que ça vaut le coup d'être
rediffusée pas ça se discute et je n'ai
pas la réponse
by the hangover donc le bras nos glaces
et que la persistance des croyances
réfuter et on vous en a parlé tout à
l'heure on a tous des croyances qui sont
faux si on les gars on y tient pour
plein de raisons et en particulier pour
la raison que on ne veut pas savoir à
quel point on est ignorant des choses ne
veux pas savoir que on sait que ça on
veut croire qu'on sait des choses on ne
veut pas être un certain parce que ce
n'est pas confortable
du coup on va se se flatter de croire
des choses on va écouter des gens qui
lui raconte des histoires et dans ce
type de format on adore les histoires de
réussite on va venir nous raconter que
bill gates il est super parce qu'il a
fait ça et ça ou leurs lots de moscou où
steve jobs est donc cherché bien il ya
plein de conférences ted où on vous
raconte la vie de ces gens là où
d'autres qui ont réussi ou reviennent
quand vous parlez de leur vie mais
est-ce que les gens qui réussissent sont
experts de leur réussite personnelle
est ce qu'ils savent pourquoi ils ont
réussi jeudi en vue puisque j'avais pas
la réponse à tout en tout cas
eux et ceux qui viennent vous parler de
la réussite des autres
il vous livre des récits motivant
stimulant édifiant inspirant il manque
un mot qui est moins à la mode c'est
pertinent toujours pertinent ce qu'on
entend par ce que au final c'est des
gens qui viennent vous parler de deux
réussites que d'obstacles à surmonter 2
2 on se on se réalise soi-même moyer est
donc en gros on vous parle de réussite
et de motivation mais enfin important de
leur sang pour sang des cadavres qui
jalonnent le mont everest ont autrefois
étaient des gens extrêmement motivé la
différence entre le mec qui meurent là
où celui qui revient c'est pas qu'ils
étaient moins motivés il ya autre chose
qui a joué la chance le hasard
l'organisation mais être motivé s'est
jamais des suffisant et oui bill gates
il était très motivé
c'est parce qu'il a réussi et donc on a
des récits intéressant et c'est super
intéressant mais est ce que est ce qu
est ce qu on apprend quelque chose de de
ça donc voir lé de réussite et on s'est
tous en vrai même si on cherchait bien
au fond de vous on sait bien qu'on
apprend beaucoup plus de nos échecs
la preuve en images c'est que les plus
gros
on apprend beaucoup plus parce que quand
on réussit tout le temps bah peut-être
qu'on n'a pas trouvé quel élément
important pour réussir mais quand on
échoue on cherche ce cas rater voyez on
retrouve vous serez amenés là là on
appris un truc dingue à force de donner
la parole à ceux qui réussissent leur
huyghe et moody's en fait c'est facile
il suffit de le vouloir
tu vois c'est pas compliqué et quand on
écoute pas le mec qui a coté karaté mais
dis moi j'en ai bavé et j'envoie lui
aussi j'ai été aussi motivé que les
autres mais en europe motivé c'est
suffisant donc aux grosses erreurs mais
on aime bien ces récits là pour diverses
raisons
à cause du vent mais pas uniquement à
cause aussi du billet de qu'on appelle
la finalité l'erreur fondamentale
d'attribution épisode 9 de la
tronche-en-biais allez voir abonnez vous
c'est le fait qu' on veut que nos succès
soit compris explicable par nous par nos
qualités personnelles c'est parce que je
suis moi et que j'ai les bonnes cases et
que je réussis et du coup enfin les
échecs c'est à cause des autres et si je
veux croire cela j'ai besoin d'écouter
ceux qui réussissent pas faire comme eux
parce que eux grâce à la qualité est
leur démarche ils ont réussi et donc ce
biais là il est extrêmement pervers
parce que d'une part je veux je néglige
de m'intéresser aux échecs
je crois que mes qualités personnelles
vont permettre de réussir et donc je
vais blâmer ceux d'hier et ceux qui
réussissent pas parce que c'est leur
faute mais si on regarde quels sont les
vrais critères qui déterminent si on va
réussir sa vie jean soit riche ou pauvre
en fait alors j'ai vous vouliez un truc
qu'on vous dit jamais en conférence ted
le travail
la motivation ça c'est vachement bien
soyez motivé travailler bien mais en
réalité c'est qu'ils sont vos parents
callen vous parler quelle école vous
fréquentez quels sont vos amis quels
sont les réseaux ou des photos de vous
et quelles sont les opportunités vous
avez la chance d'avoir le hasard c'est
ça qui times en gros vous réussit aux
nouveaux échecs mais ça vous le pouvez
rien donc quand je vous dis ça je vous
dis procès de votre pouvoir a décidé de
votre vie et donc je suis le méchant de
l'histoire
je suis désolé c'est comme ça et donc on
est très motivé à ne pas croire ce que
je vous dis donc on est très motivé à
l'écouté ce que vont dire les autres du
coup moi on m'écoute pas mais lendemain
vie dont je parle merci beaucoup pour la
médiation conclusion méfiez vous
de vous même mais au bout de nous mêmes
méfiez-vous du format tôt peut-être
conférence qui est qui va vous brosser
dans le sens du poil
méfiez vous de moi évidemment parce que
je me suis personne et je n'ai pas
d'autorité pour vous dire de qui vous
méfier et faites attention au fait qu'
il suffirait de vous poser la question
et deux aides et de ralentir vos
inférences pour vous demander mais
est-ce que ce que je crois est vrai ou
faux parce que être intelligent ça va un
bon moteur dans le bourg dans le bolide
est rationnel savoir un bon frein si
vous freinez jamais vous irez dans le
mur et si vous avez un problème vous a
été des forts vents de mur donc on peut
être hyper intelligent et est hyper
biaisé donc méfiez vous des gens
intelligents plus que les autres parce
que quand ils se rendent ils sont plus
forts et comme on est ici entre gens de
bonne compagnie intelligent et du clae
etc mêlez vous de vos mains
lorsque vous êtes les personnes les plus
dangereuses dans cette pièce parce que
vous êtes les seuls
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]